This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，最近过得怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方绝对算不上安全的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着铠甲。这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做，听听《艰难成长的教训》。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2%。这是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能以及抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。在《回顾过去》（Look Back at it）播客节目中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说都是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。1984年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。在2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控令人生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
你伪造了这份特定的测试结果两次，对吗？我只伪造了一次测试结果。这需要一支互联网侦探大军才能揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格列高利·莱斯皮安（Greg Lespian）、迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《情网难逃》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemisbeke and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, wherever you are in the world, new listeners, old listeners. It is so great to have you here back for another amazing guest episode. If I had to pick two categories that I think I get the most questions about when it comes to our 20s, it would no doubt be love and money. And although we might view those as separate topics, separate I ideas, they are actually deeply linked. How we think about money, it affects how we date, who we date, how our love stories turn out, and how we think about love will impact what money problems, money issues, money value differences we may overlook. So today, let's talk about the intersection of money, relationships, and psychology. Everything from pre-nobes,
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要面对后果了。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《情网难逃》播客。大家好。我是杰米斯贝克（Jemisbeke），欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），在这里我们探讨二十岁时的重大变化、时刻与过渡，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，无论你身处世界的哪个角落，新听众，老听众。很高兴你能回来收听另一期精彩的嘉宾访谈。如果要我选出两个我认为在二十岁时收到最多提问的类别，毫无疑问会是爱情和金钱。尽管我们可能会将它们视为独立的主题、独立的理念，但它们实际上有着深刻的联系。我们对金钱的看法会影响我们的约会方式、约会对象、爱情故事的结局，而我们对爱情的看法也会影响我们可能会忽视哪些金钱问题、金钱纠纷以及金钱观念的差异。所以今天，我们要聊聊金钱、关系与心理学的交集。从婚前协议，
to how much you should spend on a wedding, if and when you should get joint bank accounts, and why you really need to understand your money story to really show up in your relationship. Of course, I am not a financial expert, but I do have someone joining me today who is, and who is not only a financial expert, but an expert in love and money. Let's get into it. Without further ado, Jack Howard, welcome to the poker. Welcome to the Psychology of your 20s. Thank you.
到你应该在婚礼上花多少钱，是否应该以及何时开设联名银行账户，以及为什么你真的需要理解你的金钱故事，才能在恋爱关系中更好地展现自己。当然，我不是财务专家，但我今天邀请到了一位专家，他不仅是财务专家，还是爱情与金钱领域的专家。让我们开始吧。废话不多说，杰克·霍华德（Jack Howard），欢迎来到... 欢迎来到《你二十岁的心理学》。谢谢。
Thank you for having me. We were just talking about this. We have the most disparate time zones. You're in Detroit. I'm in Sydney and we've managed to make it work. So thank you. The power of technology is working for us in this moment. It's what, 6 o'clock, 6 p.m. here in Detroit.
谢谢邀请我。我们刚才还在聊这个。我们的时区差得太远了。你在底特律，我在悉尼，但我们还是设法做到了。所以谢谢你。科技的力量此刻正在为我们发挥作用。底特律现在是几点，下午6点，对吧？
And I know it's morning for you. So you're just getting your day started. I'm about to wrap it up. I know. It looks pretty good in the future. I will say the 7th of November. which is when we're recording this, which is tomorrow for you. It's a good day.
我知道对你来说已经是早上了。所以你才刚开始新的一天。而我正准备结束这一天。我知道。未来看起来挺不错的。我得说，11月7日，也就是我们录制这期节目的日子，对你来说已经是明天了。这是个好日子。
Before I go any further, because I'm going to just jump into my questions and I need the listeners to know a little bit more about you and who you are and your amazing work. Yeah, so I'm Jack Howard. I serve as head of money wellness for Ally Bank. And I bet you're thinking like, what is that? What title is that? Never heard of it before. And it's a really amazing role that I've been in for about two years.
在我继续深入之前，因为我马上就要抛出我的问题了，我需要听众对你、你的身份以及你做出的大树般的工作有更多的了解。是的，我是杰克·霍华德。我担任Ally银行的资金健康（money wellness）负责人。我敢打赌你在想，那是什么？那是什么头衔？以前从来没听说过。这是一个非常棒的职位，我已经干了大约两年了。
I've had the pleasure of working for Ally for 15 years in various roles, everything from our corporate giving, where I focused on financial education for underserved communities and corporate giving and employee volunteerism. I did that for a big chunk of my time. And then I moved to our invest business where I did a stretch role as chief of staff for the president there and decided to stay and help launch our business. personal advice business where you work with a personal, you know, wealth advisor to help you to think through retirement. And it was during that piece of my career where I was introduced to money psychology. When you're better aligned to your values, your emotions, and really understand the behaviors that you have behind some of your money decisions, it just helps you to stick to the plan. And I fell in love with it so much because one of the questions we would ask is, what is your first memory of money?
我有幸在Ally工作了15年，担任过各种不同的角色，从我们的企业慈善事业——我专注于为服务不足的社区提供金融教育，以及企业捐赠和员工志愿服务。我在这一块花了我很大一部分时间。然后我转到了我们的投资业务部门，在那里我扮演了一个扩展角色，担任该部门总裁的幕僚长，并决定留下来帮助启动我们的个人咨询业务，在这个业务中，你会与个人财富顾问合作，帮助你规划退休生活。正是在我职业生涯的那个阶段，我接触到了金钱心理学。当你更好地将你的价值观、情感以及你对某些金钱决策背后的行为真正理解结合起来时，它就能帮助你坚持计划。我太爱这个领域了，因为我们当时会问的一个问题是：你对金钱的第一个记忆是什么？
And for me, professionally and personally, it was such an amazing question because it answered so much from the work that I had done in financial literacy to even personally the ups and downs that I've had with money of really understanding the why behind your money decisions, the skills that you try to implement. a lot of people just have a hard time implementing the skills, even though you know the right thing to do. So I was in that role for a bit. And again, I fell in love with the money psychology so much that I went to our leadership and said, you know, I think this is really the future of how people will talk about money. I think it's the future of how banks will interact with customers. So less of the skills. Yes, you have to know how to save, how to invest. I can teach you how to do a budget, all those things. But really understanding that those emotions and the behaviors that will help you to implement
对我而言，无论是职业上还是个人层面上，这都是一个非常棒的问题，因为它解答了我从在金融素养领域做过的工作，到我自己在金钱上面临的起起落落中的很多疑问——真正理解金钱决策背后的“为什么”，以及你试图实施的技能。很多人就是很难将这些技能付诸实践，即使你知道该怎么做。所以我在这个职位上待了一段时间。再次强调，我太热爱金钱心理学了，以至于我找到我们的领导说：“你知道的，我认为这真的是人们未来谈论金钱的方式。我认为这是银行与客户互动方式的未来。”所以不再仅仅关注技能。是的，你必须知道如何储蓄，如何投资。我可以教你如何做预算，所有这些事情。但真正理解那些能够帮助你付诸实践的情感和行为，
the skills, having a better relationship with money, I think is the future of how we will talk about it. And they said, okay, prove it. And I was given the opportunity to start this role. And most recently, we created a free financial wellness program called Money Roots, where we teach, again, having a better relationship with money with four different workshops. And I'm sure we'll get into that more. But that's kind of been my journey and that's my current role. Oh my God. I love how you've just done so many different things. Like, and how it's all just
掌握这些技能，与金钱建立更好的关系，我认为这就是我们未来谈论金钱的方式。他们说：“好吧，证明给我们看。”于是我得到了担任这个职位的机会。最近，我们创建了一个名为“金钱之根”（Money Roots）的免费财务健康计划，我们通过四个不同的工作坊再次教授如何与金钱建立更好的关系。我相信我们接下来会对此进行更多探讨。这就是我的心路历程以及我目前的角色。天哪。我喜欢你做过这么多不同的事情。而且这一切都
linked back to this, what it sounds like, this like desire to understand people better through how like money is a tool for them. Right? And it's like, we're like psychological element of it. And you know, I think it stemmed from in my 20s. I was horrible at money. And I graduated from college with about $30,000 in student loan debt and credit card debt. And from graduating really became passionate about just having a better understanding of the skill-based side of money, specifically with credit cards. But as time continued, I was in this hamster wheel of making money. creating credit card debt and then paying it off. So I did that through my 30s. And it really wasn't
回溯到了这一点，听起来像是有一种“通过金钱作为他们的工具来更好地理解人们”的渴望。对吧？这就像是其中的心理学元素。你知道，我认为这源于我的二十岁。我对金钱一窍不通。我大学毕业时背负了大约3.0万美元的学生贷款债务和信用卡债务。从毕业起，我真正热衷于对金钱的技能层面有更好的理解，特别是关于信用卡的理解。但随着时间的推移，我陷入了赚钱、
until this money psychology piece of my financial journey and professional journey where I really got to the root of why do I do this? Why do I do the things that I do with money? And now I can put up guard rails to help me to be more successful. So it's definitely been a journey and one that I'm so excited to share with everybody else. I have a question for you about that piece you just mentioned. You graduated college. You had this debt. At the time, what do you think your biggest money mistake was?
创造信用卡债务然后还清的仓鼠轮中。我在三十多岁时一直在这样做。直到我金融之旅和职业生涯中的这个金钱心理学部分出现，我才真正找到了我为什么这样做的根源？我为什么要在金钱上做这些事情？现在我可以设置护栏来帮助自己取得更大的成功。所以这绝对是一段旅程，我非常高兴能与其他人分享。关于你刚才提到的那部分，我有一个问题想问你。你大学毕业了。你背负了这些债务。当时，你觉得你最大的金钱错误是什么？
Hmm. I think my biggest, so mine is deeply rooted in my money story. My biggest mistake then is just not realizing specifically for the credit card debt why I was creating credit card debt. And for me, it was grounded in a lot of emotional spending, which we're seeing in young people still. We have this fear of missing out and social media. You want to keep up with other people. But for me, it was emotional spending from childhood beliefs that I had learned from society and my parents.
嗯。我认为我最大的错误——所以我的错误深深植根于我金钱故事中。我当时最大的错误就是没有意识到——特别是对于信用卡债务而言——我为什么要制造信用卡债务。对我来说，这是基于大量的感性消费，我们在年轻人身上仍然能看到这一点。我们有错失恐惧症（FOMO）和社交媒体的影响。你想跟上别人的步伐。但对我来说，这是从我从社会和父母那里学到的童年信念中产生的感性消费。
All of those things created this version of me where I would spend and create debt. So I think the biggest lesson I've learned that I wish I would have known then is, is that there is no amount of money that can solve your issues when you need therapy, right? When you need emotional support for things, there's no there's no purse, there's no vacation. When you have some root issues that require additional support, you have to address that. And oftentimes, like with money or food, we will use these things to serve as a distraction. So I would tell myself, you know, let's get rid of the distractions, really address some of our root issues so that we can now show up better with our relationship with money. Speaking of relationships, what we really, what I really want to talk to you about today is the intersection between money and relationships in our 20s around marriage, yes, but also just around financial compatibility and how money actually impacts.
所有这些事情塑造了那个会花钱并制造债务的我。所以我想我学到的最大教训、也是我希望自己当时就知道的是：当你需要心理治疗时，没有任何数量的金钱可以解决你的问题，对吧？当你需要对某些事情的情感支持时，没有哪个包包，没有哪次度假可以解决。当你有一些需要额外支持的根本问题时，你必须去解决它。通常情况下，就像对待金钱或食物一样，我们会用这些东西来作为分心的借口。所以我会告诉自己，你知道的，让我们摆脱这些干扰，真正解决我们的一些根本问题，这样我们现在才能在与金钱的关系中表现得更好。说到关系，我们真正、我今天真正想和你谈的是我们在二十岁时金钱与关系的交集，关于婚姻，是的，但也是关于财务兼容性以及金钱实际上是如何影响
love in many, many ways. Let's start with this question. How important is financial compatibility in a relationship? Okay, so I love this question. One of the classes that we teach in money roots, it's really, it's called love and money, where we go deep into the very thing you just said, we go deep into, for you and your romantic partner. What are the beliefs that you have and your partner has? What are the things that you learned about money from your family and from society? And then how does this show up in your
爱情的方方面面的。让我们从这个问题开始。财务兼容性在一段关系中有多重要？好吧，我非常喜欢这个问题。我们在“金钱之根”中教授的课程之一，它实际上被称为“爱情与金钱”，我们深入探讨了你刚才所说的内容——我们深入探讨了你和你的浪漫伴侣之间的关系。你和你的伴侣有什么信念？你从家庭和社会中了解到了关于金钱的哪些事情？然后这又是如何体现在你们的
relationship? So most people don't have compatibility. You will have, you know, for whatever reason, opposites attract. You may have the spender and the saver, a nurturer or somebody who's an avoider. we all have these money personalities. So one, it's important to know kind of what your personality is, but I want everyone to avoid shame around whatever your money personality is. So I'll be honest and say for me and my partner, who I've been with since I graduated from college, we, he is more of a, more of a saver, I'm more of a spender. And I think throughout my 20s, I had.
关系中的？所以大多数人并不具备兼容性。你会发现，无论出于什么原因，异性相吸。你可能会有挥霍者和储蓄者，一个照顾者或者一个逃避者——我们都有这些金钱人格。所以第一，了解你的人格类型是很重要的，但我希望每个人都不要对你的金钱人格感到羞耻。所以我会坦白说，对于我和我的伴侣——我们从我大学毕业起就在一起了——我们，他更像是一个储蓄者，而我更像是一个挥霍者。我想在我的整个二十岁期间，我
so much shame around being a spender and I wanted to be frugal like him. But that's not who I am. I'm a spender. I'm a spender. So it wasn't until I got to a place of understanding through your money story, through really getting very aligned with your money values. That's where having compatibility can come into play because you can be opposites. But when you understand your partner's money story, you understand. understand your partner's values, it creates empathy for the differences. So it's less about your frugal and cheap and I'm a spender and, you know, you're overspending on everything, the bumping of heads to more of, oh, I understand why she is that way. I understand why he is that way. And now
对作为一个挥霍者感到非常羞耻，我想像他一样节俭。但那不是我。我是个挥霍者。我就是个挥霍者。直到我通过你的金钱故事、通过真正与你的金钱价值观高度一致，达到了一个理解的境界。这正是兼容性可以发挥作用的地方，因为你们可以是截然相反的。但当你理解了伴侣的金钱故事，你就能理解伴侣的价值观，它会为这些差异创造同理心。所以这不再关乎“你很抠门小气，而我是个挥霍者”、“你在所有事情上都过度消费”这种针锋相对，而是变成了：“哦，我理解她为什么会那样。我理解他为什么会那样。”现在
we're able to come together as a couple and create compatibility. Now we can come together without shame with empathy to say knowing that you're this person, I'm this person, how do we move forward together to create our own value system around money? And that's actually something that we teach in our money roots class, the love and money. We actually take you through understanding what that personality is, what your values are, and then how do we move forward to create something together? When you were talking about your partner, I was like, that's a familiar story. Me and my me and my partner are the same. Yeah, it's always been that way for me. Like money was, again, it's just such an emotional thing. And so of course it's going to be like reflected and show up
我们能够作为一对情侣走到一起，创造兼容性。现在我们可以毫无羞耻感、带着同理心地走到一起，去说：既然你是这样的人，我是这样的人，我们如何共同前进，围绕金钱创造我们自己的价值观体系？这实际上也是我们在“金钱之根”课程（爱情与金钱）中教授的内容。我们实际上会带你了解那个人格是什么，你的价值观是什么，然后我们如何共同前进，创造出一些东西。当你在谈论你的伴侣时，我想：这太熟悉了。我和我的伴侣也是这样。是的，对我来说一直都是这样。就像金钱一样，它再次成为一件如此情绪化的事情。所以它当然会反映出来并体现在
in your relationship. And of course there's going to be times when like, what is it? Like money is the thing that couples argue about the most. What I'm hearing you say is like you don't necessarily have to change all that much. You just have to understand and find the middle ground of like, what are we responsible for in this relationship? Is that what you're kind of saying? Yeah, so no, I think, yeah, definitely finding the middle ground and guardrails. So for me, knowing that I am a spender, I have to deeply attach my spending to my values. So I'm a huge proponent of values-based spending. And what that means is I know my top values are really beautiful things, authenticity,
你们的关系中。当然也会有这样的时刻，比如：那是什么？金钱是情侣之间争吵最多的事情。我听到你说的意思是：你其实不需要改变太多。你只需要理解并找到一个中间立场，比如：在这段关系中我们要为彼此负起什么责任？这就是你想表达的吗？是的，所以，是的，绝对是要找到中间立场和护栏。所以对我来说，既然我知道自己是个挥霍者，我就必须将我的消费与我的价值观深度绑定。所以我非常支持基于价值观的消费。这意味着我知道我的核心价值观是非常美好的东西——真实性、
generational wealth, and really my spirituality. So when I anchor, and that's a part of money wellness and money well-being, when you're able to anchor your spending, saving, and giving to your values, you get a higher return on what I like to say or higher return on joy. So for me, I know that if a spending, if I'm spending and it doesn't attach to those values, pause. Let's pause and give it 48 hours. You know, is that black pair of pants beautiful enough? Does it meet the requirement of my value of really beautiful things? Does it meet my requirement for generational wealth? And that has stopped me in my tracks.
代际财富，以及真正的精神追求。所以当我锚定——这也是金钱健康（money wellness）和金钱福祉（money well-being）的一部分——当你能够将你的消费、储蓄和给予同你的价值观锚定在一起时，你就会从我喜欢称之为“快乐的高回报”中获得更高的回报。所以对我来说，我知道如果有一笔消费，如果我的消费与这些价值观不符，暂停。让我们暂停48小时。你知道，那条黑裤子真的足够好看吗？它符合我追求美好事物的价值观要求吗？它符合我对代际财富的要求吗？这让我停下了脚步。
I'll be honest. That has stopped me in my tracks with buying things because I'll give myself that pause of, does this meet my values? And once you start spending from a place of this has to meet my values, it increases your well-being with money. And then on the other side from my partner, who is more frugal, now we're looking at it, like money is a tool for enjoyment. So we got to have a splurge account.
说实话，这确实让我停下了脚步。这阻止了我去买一些东西，因为我会给自己一个暂停的机会：这符合我的价值观吗？一旦你开始从“这必须符合我的价值观”的角度进行消费，它就会提升你的金钱幸福感。而在我伴侣的那一边，他更加节俭，现在我们换个角度看，金钱是享受的工具。所以我们必须有一个挥霍账户。
We have a splurge account. So it forces him to now say, yes, we're going to save, but we're also going to enjoy the money. We've set money aside to where if I want to, you know, spend $100 on cookies because that's my latest obsession. And he wants to spend $100 on Legos because that's his latest obsession. That's okay because we both have that wiggle room within our budget to do so. So again, it's creating those structures within your relationship to make that happen. And it's also knowing how to have the conversation. I think that's a big piece that people are missing.
我们有一个挥霍账户。这迫使他现在说：是的，我们要存钱，但我们也要享受金钱。我们留出了一部分钱，如果我想，你知道的，花100美元买曲奇饼干，因为那是我的最新执念。而他想花100美元买乐高积木，因为那是他的最新执念。这没关系，因为我们在预算中都有这样的弹性空间。所以再次强调，这是在你们的关系中建立这些结构来让它成为现实。这也是知道如何进行对话。我认为这是人们所缺少的一个重要部分。
Which I feel like we can get into in a second. I want to ask another question on this, though, before we do, which is, how do you deal with inequality in earnings when you're in a long-term relationship or you're in a just a relationship? in your 20s and beyond? What happens when one partner makes significantly more money or significantly less money? How do we kind of handle that conversation? Yeah, I think we have to have transparency. I've talked to people where they'll do a split based off of percentages and that's how much you put in. And some people wanted to make it 50-50 because it makes them feel like they're showing up and it may make you feel powerful. Again, we've got to understand the story behind that and what is preference for you as an individual. So having the transparency, one of, I love to say, money date nights. So I'm a big
我觉得我们一会儿可以讨论这个。不过在此之前我想问另一个问题，那就是：当你处于一段长期关系中，或者仅仅是一段关系中时，你如何处理收入不平等的问题？
fan of less schedule money date nights where we can meet once per week, at minimum once per month, to talk about these things and create these guidelines and go into it having topics of, are we going to have joint accounts or sweat accounts? Are we going to, how are we going to pay the bills? How are we going to be compatible with our values and our beliefs? So I think the first step is to just have these conversations and setting time aside to do so. Yeah. And also just being incredibly realistic about like, can, if this person has a certain lifestyle, could you keep up? Like, can you keep up with what they want to do and what they want to spend with still doing the 50-50 thing or with you wanting to pay your fair share? Like, I do feel like I have a couple of friends who are in
在你的二十岁及以后？当一个伴侣赚的钱明显更多或明显更少时会发生什么？我们如何处理这种对话？是的，我认为我们需要保持透明。我和一些人聊过，他们会根据百分比进行分摊，这就是你投入的金额。有些人希望做到50-50的均摊，因为这让他们觉得自己有所付出，这可能会让你觉得很有力量。再次强调，我们必须理解这背后的故事，以及作为个人的偏好是什么。所以要保持透明，我最喜欢说的一个词是：金钱约会之夜。所以我非常
relationships like this. Specifically, I'm thinking about one friend who she makes a lot more than her partner. And he was always like adamant, like, no, we're going to split everything 50-50. And it was like, well, then we can't do the things that I actually want to do in a relationship. So it was like this real, it actually got very, like, complex with them. It was like ideas of masculinity and like power and equality, but then also like enjoyment and experiences and like what matters more their relationship, like, that they can continue to play the role that they think they should play in a relationship or they can have fun with each other with the cards they're dealt. So, like, it does get very, very complex.
赞成安排较少的金钱约会之夜，我们可以每周至少见面一次，每月至少一次，来谈论这些事情并制定这些准则，带着这些话题去探讨：我们要开立联名账户还是各自独立的账户？我们要怎么付账单？我们要如何与我们的价值观和信念保持兼容？所以我认为第一步只是进行这些对话，并留出时间来这样做。是的。而且也要对以下事情极其现实：如果这个人有某种生活方式，你能跟上吗？——比如，如果你还想坚持50-50的均摊，或者你想支付你那份公平的份额，你能跟上他们想要做的事情和他们想要花的钱吗？——我的确觉得我有几个朋友正处于这样的关系中。具体来说，我想到一个朋友，她赚得比她的伴侣多得多。而他总是很坚决地说：不，我们要把一切都50-50平摊。然后这就变成了一种状况：好吧，那我们就无法做那些我真正想在恋爱关系中做的事情了。所以这变成了一个非常、实际上变得非常复杂的问题。这其中涉及到对男子气概、权力和平等的看法，但同时也涉及到享受、体验，以及什么对他们的关系更重要——是他们能够继续扮演他们认为自己在关系中应该扮演的角色，还是他们可以利用手中现有的牌和对方一起获得快乐。所以，这确实变得非常、非常复杂。
And I just want to call out everything you just said has nothing to do with money. Exactly. It has nothing to do with money. You talked about, no, you talked about gender roles and enjoyment and how do we want to have experiences together. has nothing to do with money. That's a completely separate conversation. So the problem is we don't have those conversations.
我只想指出，你刚才所说的一切都与金钱无关。完全正确。这与金钱毫无关系。你谈到了性别角色、享受，以及我们如何想要共同体验。这与金钱无关。这是一个完全独立的话题。所以问题在于我们没有进行这些对话。
And then it turns into a blow up about money. So it's so important when we think of the money date night and how do we have productive conversations with your partner to say, my values are experiences. And I do want to travel the world. And so as a partnership, we should allocate our money in this way to do these things. but again, it's realizing that those conversations need to take place. And oftentimes people just avoid it and you're ending up in an argument.
然后它演变成了一场关于金钱的争吵。所以，当我们考虑金钱约会之夜以及如何与伴侣进行富有成效的对话时，这一点非常重要：我的价值观是体验。我确实想环游世界。所以作为一种伙伴关系，我们应该这样分配我们的资金来做这些事情。但再次强调，我们要认识到这些对话是需要发生的。而通常人们只是在逃避，最终以争吵收场。
Oh, yeah. Again, I'm going to pull back that statistic that we said at the start. It's like the biggest source of conflict in relationships is money. So it's like when you're in your 20s and you're in your relationship, it's like, everybody focuses on like, oh, let's talk about our attachment styles and let's talk about our future. Like, do we want kids? Like, no, you need to have serious conversations about money early on. Like, it's actually deeply important.
哦，是的。再说一次，我要搬出我们在开头时说过的数据。这就是关系中最大的冲突之所以在哪里，那就是金钱。所以当你在二十岁且处于恋爱关系中时，每个人都专注于：哦，让我们谈谈我们的依恋风格，让我们谈谈我们的未来。比如：我们想要孩子吗？——不，你需要尽早进行关于金钱的严肃对话。这实际上具有极其重要的意义。
You do, you know, the money, the, what I love about the work we're doing here at Ally and just this whole movement that you're going to see within, I hope to see more within money psychology and money wellness is looking at money as a part of your well-being. So when you think of your social well-being, so your friendships, when you think of your community, where do you live and how do you support it, your career, you think of your fitness and your health, those are all areas of well-being. well-being. And when money is off, it impacts all of that. When you are not satisfied with your money, we're seeing through our own data that people are up at night. They can't sleep at night. It's impacting their romantic partnerships. So it's so important that even starting in your 20s, you know, not to let money be this static thing, but it is a part of your well-being and to give it its full attention in your relationship. It's so important. Okay, we're going to take a short break here, but when we return, we're going to talk about pre-nops. I'm going to talk about it. Okay. Let's
确实如此，你知道，金钱，我最喜欢我们在Ally这里正在做的工作，以及你将在金钱心理学和金钱健康领域看到、也希望能看到更多的整个运动，就是将金钱视为你福祉的一部分。所以当你想到你的社会福祉——也就是你的友谊，当你想到你的社区——你住在哪里以及你如何支持它，你的职业，你想到你的健身和健康，这些都是福祉的领域。当金钱出现问题时，它会影响这一切。当你对自己的金钱不满意时，我们通过自己的数据发现人们夜不能寐。他们晚上睡不着觉。这正在影响他们的浪漫伴侣关系。所以，即使从二十岁开始，这一点也极其重要：不要让金钱成为这样一个一成不变的东西，而是要把它看作你福祉的一部分，并在你们的关系中给予它全神贯注的关注。这非常重要。好的，我们在这里稍作休息，但当我们回来时，我们将讨论婚前协议。我会聊聊这个。好的。我们
do it. We're going to talk about weddings. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
开始吧。我们要聊聊婚礼。请继续收听。2%。这是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能以及抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些在健康产业中占据主导地位的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。任何男人都应该遵循两个黄金法则。规则一，绝对不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。
And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific. con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to
规则二，也绝对不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的好闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在新一季的《闺蜜》中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不
care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever
在意。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说：哦，见鬼，才不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜。相信我，宝贝》。
you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（double-tap）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈80年代的“快克”（crack）毒品。需要说明的是，84年对我和我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克毒品。我随时准备一整天都在聊快克，但只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapy. Careers, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
欢迎收听我的新播客节目《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，吉尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是：特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。
And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
而我们仍在追逐它，而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变得只关乎胜负。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要？你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose. On my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
那是两个不同信任层面的东西。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。加入我和吉尔·盖恩斯（Keir Gaines）的节目，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标进行真实的对话。尽在我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》。打开你免费的iHeart Radio App。搜索《艰难成长的教训》并立即收听。在2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你伪造了这份特定的测试结果两次，如此之多。我只伪造了一次测试结果。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷戈里·莱斯皮安（Gregalespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《情网难逃》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要面对后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在正义在亚利桑那州伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Something that I am so fascinated by is pre-nups. Why people get them, what they really mean. I genuinely, I'm going to be completely transparent. I have no idea what a pre-up is. Can you kind of give us a little bit of an explanation? Yeah, so essentially it's a legal document that outlines your finances and your assets. what happens to it should the marriage end.
在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《情网难逃》播客。有一件事让我非常着迷，那就是婚前协议。人们为什么要签婚前协议，它们到底意味着什么？说实话，我完全持透明态度。我根本不知道什么是婚前协议。你能给我们稍微解释一下吗？是的，从本质上讲，它是一份法律文件，概述了你的财务状况和资产。如果婚姻结束，
So we're no longer want to be together. What do we do with the house? What do we do with that bank account? All of those things helps you to think about this before you get to a place of divorce. So I look at it as almost insurance for your love. So I really want people to shift their perspective about pre-nups. And we're finding that in some of our data that is becoming less of a time. taboo topic and more of a way for couples to be transparent.
这些资产会怎么样。所以我们不再想要在一起了。我们怎么处理房子？我们怎么处理那个银行账户？所有这些事情都可以帮助你在走到离婚这一步之前提前思考。所以我认为这几乎就像是为你爱情买的保险。所以我真的希望人们改变他们对婚前协议的看法。我们发现在我们的一些数据中，它正在变成一个不那么禁忌的话题，而更多地成为情侣们保持透明的一种方式。
Yeah. So I'm going to ask some really naive questions. Do you only need a pre-up if you have existing wealth? No. And here's why. Here's why. So for everybody out there in your 20s, my question is, do you think you will have the same amount of wealth in your 40s and 50s that you have
是的。所以我要问一些非常天真的问题。只有当你拥有现有财富时，你才需要婚前协议吗？不是的。原因如下。所以对于你们所有二十多岁的人来说，我的问题是：你认为你在四十多岁和五十多岁时拥有的财富，会和你在
in your 20s? I'm hoping for most people, the answer is going to be no. So the person that you are in your 20s, the amount of assets that you have in your 20s, compared to when you're older, it changes. So I think when you set those guidelines in the beginning, when you get to a place of it didn't work out. As you mentioned earlier, money is one of the highest sources of conflicts and marriages. So if you get to a place to where this didn't work out and we want to go our separate ways, you're doing it in the beginning.
二十多岁时拥有的财富一样多吗？我希望对大多数人来说，答案是否定的。所以你在二十多岁时的那个人，你在二十多岁时拥有的资产数量，与你年长时相比，是会改变的。所以我认为，当你在开始时设定这些准则时，如果你走到了“事情没有成功”这一步。正如你刚才所提到的，金钱是婚姻中冲突的最高来源之一。所以如果你到了这一步——这没有成功，而我们想分道扬镳——你是在一开始就做好了准备。
And I have experienced this and seen it with friends. The person you are at the beginning of your marriage, when you're in love and not emotional, is a very, very different person than who you are when you are at the place of divorce. It's two different people. So if you're able to do this at a place when you're still kind to each other, where you still have best intentions for each other, and you're really, I want to say rational, do it then to where you don't have to, you know, you're battling with someone later when a lot of emotions are involved.
我经历过这种情况，也在朋友身上看到过。你在婚姻之初的那个人——当你处于恋爱中且没有情绪化时——与你走到离婚这一步时的那个人，是一个非常、非常不同的人。这是两个人。所以如果你能在彼此仍然友善、仍然对彼此抱有最好的意图、并且非常——我想说是理智的时候做到这一点，那就趁那时候做，这样你就不用，你知道的，以后在涉及大量情绪时再去和某人争斗。
So this is my second naive question, because I totally agree with you. I feel like my parents have always said, and they're still together, but like from seeing friends of theirs get divorced, like the person you marry is not the person you divorce, they're two different people. Does asking for a pre-up put pressure on the relationship? You know, there's definitely like a skeptical part in my mind and tell and please correct it if it's wrong that says, isn't that just saying like a pot of me doesn't think we're going to lost? No, I think we need to shift that, that mindset and really look at it from, we're at a place now where people are more transparent about their finances. People have, especially in your 20s and 30s, you're coming into your relationship with more assets.
所以这是我的第二个天真的问题，因为我完全同意你的观点。我觉得我的父母总是这么说——他们仍然在一起——但从看到他们的朋友离婚来看，你结婚的人和你离婚的人不是同一个人，他们是两个人。要求签署婚前协议会给这段关系带来压力吗？你知道，我脑子里肯定有一个怀疑的部分在说——如果不介意的话请纠正我，如果我说错了的话——这难道不就像是在说“我觉得我们不会长久”吗？不，我认为我们需要转变这种心态，从以下角度来看：我们现在处于这样一个阶段，人们对自己的财务状况更加透明。人们在二十多岁和三十多岁时尤其如此，你带着更多的资产进入一段关系。
So you may have children, all those things. So really understanding that this is, you're going to be. is, again, insurance should things not work out. And it's a way for us to be transparent. And it's also, if it helps, I love that it creates a level set of where are we with our finances? Because in order to have a pre-nup, you have to understand your assets and liabilities. You have to get all these things on paper for both you and your partner. So it allows you to do that level set. So I don't think, I want us to shift that and look at it as less about we're doomed and all that. And be realistic with the stats of what divorce and all those things are and saying that while we are kind to each other and have sound decision-making and not high emotions, let's just do this now to ensure that
所以你可能已经有了孩子，所有这些事情。所以真正理解这是——如果你遭遇不测，这再次是一份保险。这也是我们保持透明的一种方式。而且它也有助于——我喜欢它创造了一个基准，让我们了解我们的财务状况处于什么位置。因为为了签订婚前协议，你必须了解你的资产和负债。你必须为你和你的伴侣将所有这些东西写在纸上。所以它允许你进行那种基准设定。所以我不认为——我希望我们改变这种观念，不要把它看作是我们注定要失败之类的。而是要用关于离婚等事情的统计数据来保持现实，并说：趁我们对彼此还很友善、有健全的决策能力而且没有高度情绪化的时候，我们现在就把这个做好，以确保
it's not a problem later. Yeah. Okay. And I bet that you won't need it. Let's say that. It's just insurance. Yeah, I like this idea. Insurance for your love.
以后它不会成为问题。是的。好吧。我敢打赌你不会需要它的。我们这么说吧。这只是保险。是的，我喜欢这个想法。为你爱情买的保险。
Like, you don't buy house insurance thinking that you're going to set your house on fire. You know what I mean? You don't. You buy any kids. You still have it just in case things happen. So, and I'm hopeful that all marriages last, but in the event that they don't, just having that as a backup so that you're not fighting over things later creates. And, you know, I also think it creates a better relationship post the divorce because you didn't have to fight for all of those things. So definitely let's shift how we think about it and allow it to be a place to create transparency.
就像你买房屋保险时，并不是想着要把房子烧了，对吧？你知道我的意思吗？你不会这么想的。你可以给孩子买保险，以防万一发生什么事，保险还在。所以，我希望所有的婚姻都能长久，但万一没有，提前准备好这个后盾，这样以后就不会为了这些事情争吵。而且，我也觉得这能在离婚后建立更好的关系，因为你们不需要为所有这些事情争吵。所以我们绝对应该改变对它的看法，把它作为一个建立透明度的契机。
A great topic for money date night. Yeah, very good topic. it's maybe thing. So I have a bunch of friends who are getting married. I'm like, I feel like you get to this point in your 20s where it's like a wedding every weekend. Some of them are getting a lot, some of them are spending a lot of money on the wedding. And I saw an article that said, this is with no judgment, I really, I don't know enough. But this article that said, the more you spend on your wedding, the more likely you are to get divorced. This is an entry point for me to ask you how much do you think couples should spend on their wedding?
这是“金钱约会之夜”的一个好话题。是的，非常好的话题。也许这就是个事情。我有一群朋友正准备结婚。我觉得当你到了20多岁的时候，就像每个周末都有婚礼一样。其中一些人办得很大，一些人花了很多钱在婚礼上。我看到一篇文章说——这绝对没有评判的意思，真的，我了解得还不够多——但这篇文章说，你在婚礼上花越多钱，就越有可能离婚。这正好让我问你，你觉得情侣们应该在婚礼上花多少钱？
And do you see, which I know you might not have an answer for, but do you see maybe a correlation between spending more and that putting strain on the relationship? Let me say this. I think that from my personal, I'll just use my personal experience and what I think people should do and having this get back to your values. As a couple, as a young couple,
你是否发现——我知道你可能没有答案——但你是否发现花钱更多与给关系带来压力之间存在某种关联？让我这么说吧。我认为，从我个人的经验来看——我就用我的个人经验和我认为人们应该做的来谈——这要回归到你们的价值观上。作为情侣，作为年轻情侣，
I think it's so important to get very aligned on what your values are individually and what your values would be as a couple. And that includes what do we want this wedding to be? So I'm not going to shame your values may be having a large wedding because you have a big family and it's celebratory. It may be a part of your culture. But for someone else, it may be that they're having a smaller wedding and more intimate ceremony is who they are. Really honing in on what you want as a couple, I think is so important. and not getting pulled into what you mentioned, like, you know, I think a lot of this is like, you know, fear of missing out. You want to keep up with what your friend, all of your friends are
我认为非常重要的一点是，要在你们各自的价值观以及作为情侣的共同价值观上达成高度一致。这包括我们希望这场婚礼是什么样的？所以，我不是要贬低你的价值观，也许你想要一场盛大的婚礼，因为你有一个大家庭，而且这值得庆祝。这可能是你文化的一部分。但对另一个人来说，他们可能想要一场规模更小、更私密的仪式，这才是他们的真实写照。真正专注于你们作为情侣想要什么，我认为非常重要，不要被你刚才提到的东西所左右，你知道的，我认为很多时候这就像是对错失恐惧症（FOMO）的恐惧。你想赶上你朋友的潮流，你所有的朋友都
having big wedding. So you should have a big wedding. We tend to follow what other people do mindlessly without really understanding who we are and what we want individually. So with that in mind, I'm not going to say a dollar amount, but I do want to say that I think it has to deeply align to what your values are as a couple. And when, you spend from that point of view, it will be affordable because you will not do things that are not affordable for either of you. You'll do things that are affordable for both of you, shall I say. Yeah.
办了大婚礼，所以你也觉得应该办大婚礼。我们往往会盲目地效仿别人的做法，却没有真正了解我们自己和我们各自想要什么。因此，考虑到这一点，我不会说出一个具体的金额，但我确实想说，我认为它必须与你们作为情侣的价值观深度契合。当你们从这个角度去消费时，它就会是在你们承受能力范围内的，因为你们不会去做对你们任何一方来说超出经济能力的事。可以说，你们会做对双方来说都负担得起的事。是的。
And I like this idea of like, see, when I get married, I'm keen for a big wedding. And I have a huge family. I have a huge, like, Italian Irish family. Like, it's, there's no avoiding it. And, you know, my partner also has a huge family who we love. But yeah, it's just so interesting when you see these lavish weddings and you think that you need personalized gifts for everybody. And the day, and you think that you need everybody. Like the wedding becomes more about other people than about you.
我喜欢这种想法，你看，等我结婚时，我很渴望办一场盛大的婚礼。我有一个非常庞大的家族，我有很大一个意大利和爱尔兰血统的家族，这是没法避免的。而且，你知道的，我的伴侣也有一个我们都很爱的大家庭。但是，每当你看到那些奢华的婚礼，觉得你需要给每个人准备个性化礼物的时候，这种感觉真的很奇妙。在那个日子里，你甚至觉得你需要所有人都在场。婚礼变得更像是为了别人，而不是为了你们自己。
That's what a lot of my friends who have spent on my own wedding said that they regretted. And again, I like that you're bringing it back to values, right? It's like this is about you two showing your love for each other. Yes, like your family and friends are involved, but like it's not their wedding. Like I think the more you can spend on the enjoyment for yourself and the things that you like, this is what I'm seeing for my friends who are planning weddings who are having a good time versus those who are having like a bad time. Yeah, and you're doing it for love.
这就是我那些在自己婚礼上花了很多钱的朋友们所说他们感到后悔的地方。再说一次，我很高兴你把它引回到价值观上，对吧？这就好比这是关于你们两个人向彼此表达爱意。是的，你的家人和朋友都参与其中，但这并不是他们的婚礼。我觉得，你越能把钱花在提升你自己的享受和做你喜欢的事情上，就会越快乐。这就是我从那些正在筹备婚礼、过得很开心的朋友，与那些过得很痛苦的朋友身上看到的区别。是的，而且你们是为了爱而做这件事。
We got to get back to that. You're doing it because you're marrying your partner who you love. And you want to have an amazing experience. experience with the people who support that love. And that could be as simple or elaborate as you want it to be. But again, like you mentioned, understanding specifically for you, what do you and your partner want and not just following the crowd. Because that becomes expensive.
我们必须回到这一点上来。你们这样做是因为你们要嫁给或娶你们深爱着的伴侣。而且你们希望与支持这份爱的人们一起拥有一段美妙的经历。这可以像你们希望的那样简单，也可以像你们希望的那样精致。但再次强调，正如你所提到的，明确了解专属于你们的事情：你和你的伴侣真正想要的是什么，而不是盲目跟风。因为那样做的话代价会变得非常昂贵。
Oh, my God, yeah. Yes, I've seen it. It becomes so expensive. And I was like, I had a friend, and she won't mind me talking about this, where she was like, we spent all the, this money on like extra desserts for the guests and then they didn't eat them. They didn't eat them. Yeah. They didn't eat them. And she was like, oh, like this was such a big detail that I really, I was so stressed about coordinating how these were going to get there and like, like, blah,
哦，天哪，确实。是的，我见识过。开销变得太大了。我有个朋友——她不会介意我谈论这个——她曾说：“我们把所有的钱都花在给客人的额外甜点上了，结果他们根本没吃。他们压根没吃。”是的，他们没吃。她说：“哦，这是一个我非常纠结的细节，我为了协调这些东西怎么运到现场而焦头烂额，然后呢，巴拉巴拉……”
and she was like, and I asked her, I was like, how much, tell me truthfully, how much did you spend on like, I think she was like the cocktails and the dessert. And she was like over $3,000. And I was like, that's, and she's like, I just wish we're just like, that could have been like part of our honeymoon fund. You know what I mean? So, yeah, I like that you're bringing back to values. Yeah, I think also as brides, or in life, in life, we can get so caught up in perfect moments. Yeah. You have this, you know, you envision what this day will be and it should be perfect.
她说，我问她：“说实话，告诉我，你在比如鸡尾酒和甜点上花了多少钱？”她说超过了3000美元。我说：“天呐。”她说：“我只希望我们当时能把这笔钱当作蜜月基金的一部分。”你懂我的意思吗？所以，是的，我喜欢你把它拉回到价值观上。是的，我也觉得作为新娘，或者在生活中，我们常常会陷入对完美时刻的执念中。是的。你会有这样一种构想，你知道的，你设想这一天会是怎样的，并且它应该是完美的。
But we all know, life is not perfect. Things, something's going to go wrong that day, big or small, you know. And just creating space for that day going into it to know that why am I here? Why am I here? And what are my values for doing this? And it helps you to not really sweat the small stuff of the day because those things will come up. You know, you spent more on the, and your guests won't know. That's the other thing.
但我们都知道，生活并不完美。那天总会有这样那样的事情出错，或大或小，你知道的。在迎接那一天时，为这种不完美留出心理空间，并清楚地知道：我为什么在这里？我为什么在这里？我这样做的价值观是什么？这会帮助你不会去为当天的区区小事而烦恼，因为那些事情迟早会发生。你知道的，你在某些地方花了更多钱，而你的客人们甚至根本不会察觉。这就是另外一点了。
Your guests will have no idea that you didn't buy more dessert, you know, or you didn't have that extra decoration. They'll never know. again, they're there to support your love. So let that be the focus. Yeah, I love that. One final money dilemma that we see in relationships is shared bank accounts. What do you think about people who are in early stages of their relationship? Maybe they've just moved in together getting a shared bank account. Is it safer at the beginning to just continue to spend separately or is it wise to kind of, you know, get that extra interest or combine finances for convenience? What have you seen that kind of works for couples?
你的客人们根本不会知道你没有多买甜点，你知道的，或者你没有搞那些额外的装饰。他们永远不会发现。再次强调，他们到场是为了支持你们的爱情。所以，让这成为核心焦点。是的，我太喜欢这个观点了。我们在恋爱关系中看到的最后一个金钱困境是共享银行账户。对于处于恋爱关系早期的情侣，你怎么看？也许他们刚刚搬到一起，就去开一个共享银行账户。在刚开始时，继续各自花各自的钱会更安全，还是为了方便而顺便赚点额外利息或合并财务会更明智？根据你的观察，哪种方式对情侣更管用？
Yeah. So I'm going to give you a little bit of data and then a little bit of just what I'm seeing from the world we live in. So I've had the pleasure. I did a graduate certification and financial health and wellness from Texas Tech, the financial planning school. And there I learned through one of our, you know, literature reviews. that technically relationships where you share bank accounts are better because of the transparency. So you just have more transparency within the relationship. You're more aligned.
好的。所以，我先提供一点数据，然后再谈谈我从我们生活的世界中所看到的情况。我有幸在德克萨斯理工大学金融规划学院完成了金融健康与养生的研究生认证。在那里，通过我们的文献回顾学习，我了解到，从技术上讲，拥有共享银行账户的伴侣关系由于透明度的提高而表现更好。因此，你们在恋爱关系中会有更高的透明度。你们的步调会更一致。
However, I think we also have to take into account that people are getting married later. They have more assets. So it may be difficult to come in and share everything. So again, I think this is a conversation to where do we have, depending on your assets and the level of comfort that you have? I think you want to have, I think the key here is transparency. That's what I think the key is. So is it that we have certain views of each other's accounts? When we have a money date night, do we talk about our accounts if they're separate?
然而，我认为我们也必须考虑到，现在人们结婚的时间更晚了。他们拥有更多的资产。所以一上来就共享一切可能会比较困难。因此，再次说明，我认为这是一个需要探讨的问题：根据你们的资产和你们的舒适程度，我们要怎么做？我认为关键在于透明度。这就是我认为的关键所在。那么，是我们能看到彼此账户的某些视图吗？当我们进行金钱约会之夜时，如果账户是分开的，我们会谈论各自的账户吗？
But I do want to take into account that some people just come into relationships with more assets. So separating things may be difficult. keeping that in mind, the key again is the transparency to where we're not hiding money, where we get into financial infidelity, things like that. So we want to have that transparency to ensure that we know what the assets are. We know we've agreed upon if we're going to share or not. I personally am a fan of I have my own account. My partner has his own account.
不过我确实想考虑到，有些人进入恋爱关系时带来了更多资产。所以把事情分得清清楚楚可能会比较困难。记住这一点，关键依然是透明度，我们要做到不藏私房钱，不会陷入财务不忠之类的状况中。所以我们需要这种透明度，以确保我们清楚资产状况。我们已经商量并确认好是否要进行共享。我个人其实挺支持这种方式的：我有我自己的账户，我的伴侣有他自己的账户，
And then we have one account where we share our expenses, our shared expenses, that works for me. But again, have that conversation so that you can go into it knowing what each person feels comfortable with. But according to the academic data, when you share it, it helps your relationship. I love how I love this conversation. And I'm so grateful for all the advice that you're giving us on like the more juicy, controversial parts of money and relationships. I have one final question for you. It's the question we ask all of our guests, which is what is one piece of advice? you have for people in their 20s that has nothing to do with what we talked about today, though,
然后我们有一个共同的账户来支付我们的开销、共同开销，这种模式对我来说很管用。但话说回来，一定要进行沟通，这样你们在开始时就能了解每个人觉得舒适的底线在哪里。不过根据学术数据，当你选择共享时，它确实对你们的关系有益。我太喜欢这场对话了。我非常感谢你给我们提供的所有建议，尤其是关于金钱与爱情中那些更带劲、更具争议的部分。我还有一个最后的问题要问你。这是我们问所有嘉宾的问题：对于20多岁的人，除了我们今天谈论的内容之外，有什么建议是无关紧要的、
nothing to do with money, nothing to do with relationships even. Oh, my goodness. What would I tell 20-year-old Jacqueline, life is short and enjoy the people that you love. Life is short and enjoy the people that you love because, you know, I'm 44. I'll be 45 in March. And over the years, I'm also a breast cancer survivor. So there's layers to that, too, of you get to a. place of, for me in my 20s, a lot of my 20s was about checking boxes. So it was,
和金钱毫无关系，甚至和恋爱关系也毫无关系的？哦，天哪。我会对20岁的杰奎琳说些什么呢？生活短暂，去享受你所爱的人吧。生活短暂，去享受你所爱的人，因为，你知道的，我今年44岁了。三月份我就要45岁了。这些年来，我也是一名乳腺癌幸存者。所以这其中还有更多层次的意义，你会到达这样一个阶段——对我来说，在我20多岁的时候，我的大部分时间都在忙着打勾完成清单。所以它包括：
graduate from college, check, get married, check, have kids, check, you know, have my retirement accounts check. And then when I was diagnosed with breast cancer at 30. And with that, it really reset who I was as a person to really understand that I'm here to have experiences with the people that I love. And when you have, When you live life from that standpoint, a lot of these small things, like we're talking about decorations at a wedding or did I get enough desserts, when you look at life through that lens, it becomes so much more joyful. And that's one of the reasons why I love my work at Ally because I'm in a position to help people to use money as a tool to have joy, to have a return on joy, as a tool to have experiences. and use it to, you know, love and enjoy the people around them. And when you look at life through that lens, it becomes so much sweeter.
从大学毕业，打勾；结婚，打勾；生孩子，打勾；你知道的，建立我的退休账户，打勾。然后当我在30岁被诊断出患有乳腺癌时，与之相伴的是，它彻底重塑了我作为人的内核，让我真正明白我来到这里是为了和爱我的人一起体验生活。而当你拥有了这种心态——当你从这个立场去生活时，许多琐碎的小事情，比如我们刚才谈到的婚礼上的装饰，或者我买的甜点够不够——当你通过这种视角看待生活时，生活就会变得快乐得多。这也是我热爱在Ally的工作的原因之一，因为我处于这样一个位置：我可以帮助人们把金钱当作一种工具来获得快乐，获得快乐的回报，作为一种体验生活的工具，并用它来（你知道的）爱和享受他们周围的人。而当你透过这个镜头看待生活时，一切都会变得更加美好。
So stop checking boxes and enjoy life, enjoy those experiences because life is short. That's phenomenal advice. And advice I probably need to take myself. So definitely, definitely a good piece there. I want to thank you so much for coming on the podcast, Jack. Honestly, you are so wise and just so lovely to talk to. I feel like our conversation was just like effortless and I so appreciate your time. So thank you so much again.
所以，别再忙着在清单上打勾了，去享受生活，去享受那些体验吧，因为生命苦短。这是绝妙的建议。这也是我可能需要身体力行去采纳的建议。所以，这绝对是一个极佳的观点。我非常感谢你来到这个播客，杰奎琳。老实说，你太有智慧了，而且非常讨人喜欢。我觉得我们的对话轻松自如，我非常感激你抽出时间。所以再次非常感谢你。
Thank you. And check us out, AllyMoneyroots.com. The sessions are all free. Yeah. I feel like this. I know. I was just about to say that. I was like, I feel like I need to do money in love.
谢谢。去看看我们的网站吧，AllyMoneyroots.com。这些咨询课程全部都是免费的。是的。我觉得这个……我懂。我正想这么说呢。我想说我觉得我需要去做“金钱与爱情”的课程。
I'm like going to make Tom do it with me. Going to make him sit down. I think it would be like super helpful for us. So I appreciate it. I'll make sure that I leave links in the description below for where you can find Jack and all her work and where you can do money in love. But if you enjoyed this episode as well, make sure that you subscribe. Make sure you give us a five-star review. And check us out on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to, you know, suggest some episodes, have some feedback,
我要让汤姆跟我一起做。要让他坐下来陪我。我觉得这对我们来说会超级有用。所以我很感激。我一定会把链接留在下方的简介里，大家可以在那里找到杰奎琳以及她的所有工作，还能参与“金钱与爱情”的项目。如果你也喜欢这一期节目，请务必订阅。请给我们一个五星好评。并在Instagram上关注我们：@That Psychology Podcast。如果你想（你知道的）推荐一些节目、提出一些反馈，
have your own questions of how money and love have intersected for you, preempts, marriage, any of those things. I would love to hear it. Until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere,
或者分享你自己关于金钱与爱情如何交织的疑问，比如婚前协议、婚姻，或者任何类似的事情。我很乐意听到你们的声音。我们下期再见，保持安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯为您带来的《艰难一课》。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的生活经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方其实都是不够安全的，
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套隐形的铠甲？它向世界释放出的信号是：你可不是好惹的。然而，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难一课》。2%。这是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the... IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。注意，是“百分之二”。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends, trust me, babe, on the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you got your podcast.
当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个声名狼藉的诈骗犯时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱惩罚。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听播客《闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》。
I got you. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down,
包在我身上。在播客节目《回首往事》（The Look Back at it）中。从1979年开始，这对我是个非常重要的时刻。1984对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the I Heart Radio
并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段岁月的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。1984年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人群体来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。请在iHeart Radio收听《回首往事》
You have Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
你可以在Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方找到它。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探出动，才能揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男子：格雷格、莱斯利，
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的推进，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了法律后果。请在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。